hello in this video we'll talk about
cheriak higashi syndrome
which is a rare inherited complex immune
disorder
it usually occurs in childhood and
characterized by reduced pigment in skin
and it is very comparable to albinism
so in this child you can see there is
oculocutaneous aluminism especially near
the eyes
and it is associated with
immunodeficiency and increased
susceptibility to bacterial infection
and in a moment we would understand what
is the reason behind it
and there is also an increased tendency
to acquire bruise or
bleeding
and in this video it would be totally
understandable why these manifestations
are there
first of all this particular disease is
an autosomal recessive disorder
next
the major molecule which is dysregulated
is a gene
known as list or lysosomal trafficking
regulator gene which is mutated
now this lysosomal trafficking gene
which is situated in 1q42 q43 region
this gave rise to a specific regulator
protein that helps to take specific
substances inside the lysosome so in
nutshell
this particular gene product help in
lysosomal trafficking
so when this gene is mutated this
product is not made and overall
lysosomal trafficking is disrupted and
this leads to decreased phagocytosis
now decrease in phagocytosis could have
multiple implications it could lead to
albinism peripheral neuropathy recurrent
pyogenic infection and many of these
things so let us try to understand the
reason behind all of these aspects
lysosomes mediate degradation of
extracellular particles such as a
bacteria or let's say a virus by forming
endolysosomes
it can also recycle
senile or organelles
so now we try to understand
how these processes could be affected in
cheriak gases syndrome
in normal situation let's say a bacteria
entered our body and it would be
engulfed by a particular cell type and
then it would fuse with lysosome to form
phagolysosome eventually the content of
the lysosome the harsh lysosomal enzymes
would actually degrade these bacteria
that's how this threat is eliminated
but in sharia highgasses syndrome due to
a defective lysos
defective least gene product
the trafficking
of substances in the lysosome is
defective
and one of the implication is the
lysosome cannot
fuse with the endosome and the
phagolysosome cannot be formed
now that is why
bacteriolysis could not occur
and this affects several cell types
especially
the phagocytotic cells of the immune
system such as dendritic cell and the
macrophages whenever
bacteria or virus invaded our body
macrophage and the dendritic cell try to
engulf that pathogen
with by the process of phagocytosis
and inside
the phagosome
lysosome actually fuse with these
endosomes and ultimately creates
phagolysosome where the bacterias are
dead
by the harsh lysosomal enzymes so
bacteriolysis can take place
but in cheria higas syndrome due to this
faulty least gene product this
fusion of lysosome and the endosome does
not take place as a result there is no
bacteriolysis and body is more and more
susceptible
to
bacterial infection
another cell type which is highly
affected due to this mutation is the
cytotoxic c
t cells
cytotoxic t cells can secrete specific
uh
granules which are known as
perforin and granzymes
this can actually demolish
the cells which are infected by virus
especially that induce
apoptotic pathway so ultimately the cell
dies
and that is how cytodoxic t cell work
but in this list gene mutant these
granules can not actually be secreted
properly
and as a result
body is more susceptible to viral
infection as well
in shedding hygasi syndrome one of the
important thing that we see
frequent bruising on the skin
and
sometimes even bleeding because the
platelets are also affected in these
in this genetic situation where list
gene is mutated
that is why we see frequent bruising and
sometimes even bleeding which is a kind
of severe
now another implication of
cheriakography syndrome is
neuropathy or progressive
neurodegeneration
where the neurons are severely affected
because neurons also need lysosomal
function for their uh normal physiology
and in cheriaki gases syndrome that
doesn't happen that is why the risk of
neuropathy or progressive
neurodegeneration is increased but have
you ever wondered why these
children's are kind of like albino why
why they have albino like
syndromes because
lysosomes are also crucial for
melanin secreting melanocytes in the
screen in the skin
now
once
these gene list gene is actually mutated
the melanocytes can no longer secrete
melatonin melanin
in the skin
so melanin is the pigment that helps our
skin coloring that is why these patients
who are affected by cheria cagassy
syndrome are often albinos and this is
very visible in the
sub ocular area
now let us try to understand what is the
distinguishing feature or histological
feature of cheriaki gassy syndrome
so in cheddar kigasi syndrome we can see
giant granules in uh granulocytes as
shown here in this particular image and
these are
kind of like granules which cannot be
used together
now there is no specific treatment for
cheriakagasi syndrome so far but it has
been seen that if detected early bone
marrow transplant
can give good result in some patients
also secondary infections like bacterial
or viral infections can be treated with
specific
antibiotic cocktails or antivirals
sometimes since these patients are
highly highly susceptible to
staphylococcus aureus the abscess can be
sometimes surgically drained out or
removed these are some secondary
treatment options that are available so
in this video what we learned so far is
the pathophysiology of sharia kagasi
syndrome we learned the immunological
basis of sharia ki gas syndrome and
lastly we looked at the diagnosis and
the possible treatment option of
childhood syndrome so i hope this video
was comprehensive enough to give you all
the necessary information if you like
this video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe you
can follow me on instagram facebook or
even into twitter my profile id is
provided here and please you can support
my channel in patreon and your support
means a lot for me and it would help me
to create more such contents for you
guys only so do let me know in the
comment if you have any suggestions
thank you thanks for listening